with any agenda to try to talk about
covet i don't want to talk about it if
anything we've been
ignoring relevant developments in recent
weeks
as more and more players end up on the
kova 19 reserve list we talk about the
big names but we don't
stop the show to talk about gee look the
numbers are going up and
a lot of guys are on this covet 19
reserve list i mean we
we talk about when it's significant and
today it's significant because the nfl
developed several weeks ago intense next
level covet 19 protocols for certain
teams based upon
whether to what extent they were on the
fringes of an outbreak
as of yesterday those protocols
enhanced intents apply to every
team as of saturday every team
this is an acknowledgement by the nfl
chris yeah
this isn't getting any better no it's
getting worse
and they're reaching the critical mass
of players who have it
of players who have been in close
contact with them
to the point where they really have to
be concerned about
shutting things down not the entire
league
but losing games that would go to a week
18 and ultimately not being able to make
them up because
it just feels like things are kind of
teetering right on the edge
and they've got to get it under control
especially with thanksgiving coming i
think a lot of people are concerned
about
definitely americans generally defying
the recommendation to not have
gatherings on thanksgiving
and that that's going to spark a huge
wave a tidal wave of infections into
december and that may be the thing
chris that finally knocks the nfl over
the edge yeah
well i think it's the the first right
move here
as far as which like which way the world
is moving at this moment
i mean yeah it's it's everywhere yeah i
talk to parents here in
you know my hometown with my kids and
all that you know
it's it's everybody knows someone right
now oh you know this person got kova
it's so
yeah i mean we're in danger of it
starting to creep into teams or at least
teetering on the edge there to where we
don't want that to happen
i get this i think this is the right
move to make here right right at this
moment
yeah let's get strict right now before
thanksgiving
it's spreading throughout the country
right uh we're not gonna do a bubble
and it's also like another warning shot
to go for all the players be like listen
this
you know we're we're going to code red
here
yeah we're going to code red because we
want to finish the season we want you
guys to get paid we want to play do all
those things
and also hey it's code red because of
the things that are going on
on outside the facility and hopefully
like what goes on in the facility
will make players who we've talked about
i don't think are necessarily in fear of
it
but just realize oh okay i went through
this strict day
here at football you know i gotta
continue to be strict once i leave
football it's it's on their radar more
this way too and i think that's a
positive at least for the players in
that standpoint
and i think the reality is no amount of
care away from the facility
is going to keep a player from
potentially being
exposed unless he goes straight
home and into a room
that is sealed off from the rest of the
house with no opportunity to interact
with any of the other human beings in
the building who may have left
who may have been infected whether at
school although schools are
are converting back to virtual
throughout the country yeah gradually
but not completely
or a spouse who leaves the the building
the house during the day or a parent who
may live with
a player whatever whatever it may be
anybody that you reside with
can have it and give it to you when you
go home and as the numbers go up the
chances of that happening
go up as well here are the basic
intensive protocols that apply now that
all
teams are in them all meetings must
occur
virtually no in-person meetings of any
kind at the facility masks must be worn
by all players and staff
during practice that's one all players
and staff during practice
no more than 10 players in the weight
room at any time i'm surprised that
isn't the standard protocol frankly
and no gatherings of players or other
team personnel away from the facility
now this is the one that i i look at and
i say
where's the union in this not that i'm
advocating that the union stand up and
say we'll have gatherings if we damn
well please
but i don't know how much of this the
nfl can do
on its own without the union saying
we're okay with it
and for all i know the union signed off
on it this becomes a stew
of clauses and principles and protocols
while we're also trying to cover the
sport
it's one thing to talk about this stuff
in june or july but we're in the middle
of a football season we're trying to
focus on the season
while this other thing percolates off to
the side
and if they are going to get the union
to agree to anything chris the best way
to solve
all of this is just finally do the home
market bubble
why won't they just put the guys in
hotels
for the rest of the season there isn't
much of a season left six weeks
from this sunday the regular season ends
and 18 of the teams are done
and for the 14 that will still play you
should
welcome staying in a hotel because that
ensures that you'll have your full
complement of players
for your single elimination playoff
games but i still
think that the league in the union are
engaged in this clumsy stare down
as to who's going to blink first because
the league doesn't want to have to make
a concession
to the nflpa to get the players to agree
to stay in a hotel
and the nflpa doesn't want to just say
okay fine we'll do it
they're waiting for the nfl to offer
them something to make it worth their
while
and it's a game of chicken that
ultimately is going
to potentially blow up on everyone if
they wait
for the sport to implode before they
finally say
you know we probably should have had a
home market bubble
it's still mike i'm with you i mean it
still seems the safest most sure way
to do things but you know two things
one the players and coaches don't want
it you know
i know that there's some coaches and
teams that are doing that a little bit
on their own but i think the majority no
they're they're still looking over that
little
serenity sanity whatever it is where
they want to go home at the end of the
day and see their wife their girlfriend
whatever their kids all of that so some
of
some of that is just not you know you
know players aren't willing to
shut up i know i know they have plenty
of time to do that if the sports chefs i
know
and i'm just saying that i'm just giving
you a little look into what they're
feeling there and then i i think the
other thing too
you know one is the nfl really pushing
that you know are they really like
that right no they're not no because
they no here's why
because they know that they can't force
the players to do it
okay so they don't want they don't want
to make an issue of it they're being
coy this is the subtlety of bargaining
all right you don't want to make it look
like you really want it because then the
nflpa says yeah if you really want it
you better offer us something and
and you can ask for anything if you're
the nfl pa because this is a major
change
of work circumstances where you're
forcing guys to not live at home you
make them 24 hour a day employee yeah
you're right you do
and then something you know the nflpa
probably will want something back you
know and again i don't really understand
that i don't think we should go too far
with those type of things i mean
hey yeah nfl players you're getting
money to play and staying healthy and
all those things
so i get that but i guess what i'm
really saying too
is you know the nfl has been so
steadfast
all along with talk of you know no
bubble
and our protocols are perfect and if
they're followed
there should be no problems so i just
wonder
how much conversation has really been
done there about that that's that's all
i was trying to say i
really have no idea but i just know
they've been almost stubborn to say what
they've said in place is perfect
and i just wonder if that's really their
thought or just you know
talk it's talk because they know they
can't get the thing
that truly would be perfect without
putting themselves in a difficult spot
financially or
otherwise when dealing with their union
yeah because
here's the great flaw in the nfl's
approach nfl's approach is simple
yeah we know guys are going to get it
they're going to go home and they're
going to get it
and we test them every day and the
moment we know that someone has it
that's when we activate the
effort to identify anyone who's been in
close contact
those guys are gone for five days now
you know they
they basically identify the positive
they draw the circle around them and
anyone who was too
close to him is gone we have neutralized
the threat
threat neutralized as michael scott once
said
the problem is we're getting to a point
where it's not just going to be that
one guy who solders into the building
gets his nose swabbed and you find out
the next day that he was positive all
along
and we got to take maybe three or four
guys out you're gonna have
two guys three guys five guys
right and it becomes exponential
the number of people that go out the
door with him
under this protocol that's the problem
as the numbers keep going
up and up and up and up and december
is going to be far worse than november i
believe based upon the trend lines that
we've seen throughout the country
that's when this this procedure is going
to
collapse upon itself because you're not
going to have anyone left
look at the raiders yeah well yeah the
raiders
one guy test positive cleveland feral
test positive
and seven guys go with him out the door
that's what's gonna happen and you're
gonna multiply it
by two by three how many how many
multiples
of one guy and all the other guys who
are in close contact with him
is it gonna take before a team just
physically can't play now one of the
reasons going to the enhanced protocols
chris they don't want one guy to take
seven down with him yeah and the mere
fact
that all these other guys are knocked
out for five days because they were
in too close of a contact with cleveland
farrell
it shows you that either teams aren't
following the protocols or the protocols
aren't good enough because you shouldn't
have that many guys the idea is
one guy tests positive nobody is in
sufficiently close contact
that they have to be removed from the
building for five days so i think that's
what they're trying to get to
so when there are two three four five
seven ten guys positive
no one goes down with them i think that
may be unrealistic but that's what
they're trying to do yeah i i it makes
sense i mean
especially to what you're saying here i
mean you're right we got
a lot of guys that were in contact with
people
with the las vegas raiders and now you
know they're handicapped again for this
weekend in a sunday night football game
where i'm sitting here going
are we gonna ha are we gonna get part
two raiders gets canceled on sunday
night football and they're gonna move
this game at some point
i mean i'm a little worried about that
in general mike do you think
that maybe the nfl is just waiting till
after thanksgiving
and then maybe they'd make a push then
to the to the to the
nfl pa at that moment knowing that
players and coaches are not going to do
this at this time with thanksgiving i
just don't even think that's possible
you know so i just don't think it's
realistic because the players won't do
it
but do you think they will try to make a
push there into december because of like
what you said the trends are saying it's
gonna get serious here
soon i think that this may be just
laying the foundation
for what comes next and getting the
union and the players to understand
that the next step
is putting everyone in a hotel right and
what the nfl wants and it's
it's it's sad that it comes to this but
this is the way it works
in a collectively bargained relationship
union and management union has rights
management just can't say everybody's
staying in a hotel now in dallas
the coaches and the staff are all
staying in a hotel because they're not
unionized jerry jones can say you're
doing it
what are they going to say no i quit
right right so you got to do it it's a
job got to do it got to stay in the
hotel
the the union says no no and that's what
they're trying to avoid they're trying
to avoid the showdown
where the union says checkmate they're
trying to get
the union to self-checkmate themselves
as we would say
they want the union to come to them and
say hey we have an idea
instead of all these enhanced protocols
instead of all this stuff where guys get
knocked out for five days and they can't
play we got a bunch of guys who are
upset i can't say pissed off apparently
because they bleep us in england now
when i say pissed off sorry i said not
me
but you got a bunch i know that's weird
somebody emailed last night they bleeped
me when i said it but they didn't
believe him yeah i'm just a little
better
yeah a little smoother unfair unfair
but but i i think that they're hoping
the union
will be the one to say hey you know what
are you willing to pay for 32 hotels
so our guys can just stay there and and
i think that's one of the reasons why
the nfl's been coy about it chris one of
the reasons why they're acting like they
don't want it it's no different than the
dramas that
play out in households throughout the
country where
you know what you want and you know how
you got a bargain for it and you know
how you got to plant the seed and you
can't make it look like you'll want it
if you make it look like you want it
then maybe you're not going to get it
and and that's i think that's the core
of this and it's a shame
for something this serious that it
reverts back to this awkward dance
of who has to give up what to get what
the league wants which is
everyone in a hotel yeah i just i don't
think i mean i just don't think that
moment's ever gonna happen
unless the nfl just came to the nflpa to
make some
extravagant deal or something like it's
not gonna happen
until again it goes back to our old
thing here
until people start losing paychecks that
that's really all there is to it
and if you're and if i mean right now
players aren't scared they're going oh
yeah we've had a few outbreaks with our
team here and there
and blah blah blah and coaches are same
thing but we're playing
so it's not like the fear of death or
like you know the fear of not being paid
or
the season being ruined is not really
there they keep just going hey we're
it's pain in the butt this year
what we're doing we're making it happen
here what we're doing we're making it
happen though
and we're getting paid you know so that
to me is where
i don't know if the players really will
ever care
oh i got covet i can't play the next two
weeks doesn't matter we're gonna make
the concession i i just that's where i
don't know if that ever happens until
it really hits happens until it really
hits home
to where like you're saying it's either
starts to be family members or getting
sick
or people in the organization are
getting so sick that we can't play and
you're not getting paid and just
unfortunately
it seems like it'll have to get dire
before that kind of move is made
not getting paid is the key and it's
amazing that so many people still
continue to insist it's not a real
problem how can there not be
hundreds of thousands of people whose
lives have been touched by this by now
now i don't personally know anyone who's
gotten
extremely sick or or died from it at
least not within
you know the immediate bubble there have
been people in the community that you
know there's a guy that i've known for
years that was on a heart lung machine
for multiple days that's one of the
treatments that they're using for the
worst of the cases but
we just need to get people to understand
this is a real thing and they need to
take steps
to prevent themselves from getting and i
think the lost paychecks will be the
most immediate way to get the message
across to a
broad swath of players if games are lost
and that agreement's already been made
if games are cancelled or suspended
the players don't get paid forfeits open
question
that's why we haven't heard much talk
about right it's in recent right frankly
because there's an open question and the
league of course will say oh they don't
get paid for that
okay fine go look at the agreement where
does it say they don't get paid for
forfeits where does it say in the rules
that a forfeited game is anything other
than a completed game with a final score
of two to nothing checkmate there that's
part of this dance
but i think you're right chris it needs
to get to the point where the players
say holy crap and i i talked to a coach
before the season who was consulting
with an epidemiologist because
all due respect the nfl's program here
is being run by a brain guy
not a dr fauci type which has issues
frankly i would not want if i was still
practicing law
to handle a case that fell into
an area that i'd never handled before
right it would take a lot of work and i
would always feel like i was a step
behind
and boy if i had only been doing this
for the last 30 years i'd feel a lot
more comfortable about doing it now
but an epidemiologist predicted that
they'll be given the sheer number of
players coaches staff there'll be a
couple of deaths
minimum at some point and we saw the
report yesterday that ed donatello the
broncos defensive coordinator
man won't be back is still not back i
don't know when he'll be back but he's
still not back with the team after
fighting cover 19.
and i've heard other names and see this
is where i think
the retreat to hipaa is bullcrap
this is not leprosy this is not some
stigmatizing disease the only thing
stigmatizing about is you were dumb
enough to get it but now at this point
where it's everywhere
i think that goes out the window too and
i think it's important for
everyone you're talking about being
involved in a business that is an
inherent public trust in all the
communities where the teams are located
i think they should not hide behind
hipaa or any privacy interest
when it comes to this and it's so
bizarre it's weird every day it's
surreal oh
you get the report well so-and-so well
this team broncos have a guy
who's tested positive well who is it
well we can't tell you and then at four
o'clock eastern they put the guy on the
coveted 19 reserve list that's how they
tell us
i mean it's just dumb right it's dumb
and uh you know i poked around heard a
name last night a fairly prominent name
for people who pay
extremely close attention to the sport
pokemon sorry i can't tell you anything
we need to know how bad this is we need
to know
if there are staff members and coaches
who are fighting for their lives
wouldn't that be helpful to get other
people to take this more seriously yeah
i think that's the big thing yeah
i mean it'd be good for people in the
spotlight to continue to just shed
light when they do get it know people to
just let people know that this is real
this is not
you know some political talking point or
anything like that
and there's still some out there that
don't really buy into the home some
some i know it's a lot it's it's 30 i
don't get it and you know
you know again i've known people who've
gotten covered like you know to you
nothing serious i've had a few though
where hey i know a person and the mother
died
you know know a person and the the aunt
died
right i've had so it it's it's real i
don't know what else to say
and ed donatello i mean just
that he's the perfect example that it's
real ed donatell i know him
he was with him in the denver broncos
there's not a better
soldier in football as far as an
assistant coach
somebody who loves his job i mean for
you
he he must be miserable for him not to
be there
you he is not the kind of guy he's the
kind of guy that's like
hey i lost my right leg yesterday but
don't worry i'll be at work tomorrow
like he's going he's going so for him
not to be able to
to be there you know for a human being
like him and i know how his brain works
and everything
it must be really a struggle because
he's just not the type of guy that would
take any time off or do anything like
that
and uh you know that if that i bet you
that opens up some eyes in that denver
organization to
go whoa if he's not here and it's like
that you know that that'll make me be
a little bit more careful and there's
still
an issue that has never been properly
addressed by the nfl and i remember
asking about it
when we were trying to figure out which
players were going to exercise their
rights to opt out
the nfl had no opt-out procedure
league-wide for coaches or other staff
members
yeah think about it if anybody's in a
position where they should be
considering an opt-out
it's some of the older people people who
have lived long enough to develop
the comorbidities that make you more
susceptible to a bad outcome
to covet 19. some teams it never came up
other teams you know you had to ask and
you get they
became on on the coaches and the owners
themselves to just go
like you sure you want to team by team
reach out right team
team by team and plenty of teams as i
understand it
never even mentioned it it's just like
here we are
we work and that's what we do and there
aren't going to be opt-outs basically it
was never announced
it was never hung on the refrigerator no
opt-outs it just
the occasion to opt out never was there
the opportunity to opt out never was
there and i had a coach tell me back
before the season
this is the time
where it's imperative for the coaches to
have a union
and they they don't they never have and
they probably never will although maybe
in the aftermath of this
you'll finally see a push by coaches to
unionize the concern is
that there will be retaliation for
management and that you will lose your
job and they'll find somebody else
to come in and be the coach it's a lot
easier especially if there'd be a work
stoppage all right all the coaches are
fired let's go find other guys there's
plenty of guys out there
who would want to come coach football
and plenty of guys out there who have
the skills and abilities to do it
not at the same level but close enough
remember they did it with the officials
oh all the replacements will be just as
good remember that until the fail mary
yeah
the commissioner would say that with a
straight face all the replacements will
be just as good so
that that's one of the reasons why ed
donatello had to keep showing up for
work every day didn't have an
opportunity to opt out with some sort of
a stipend that would carry him through
the season if he chose to do it
it was all left to the teams and uh it's
created this situation where maybe some
of these guys have gotten sick and we
just don't know because they won't say
so and
i'm surprised frankly that it came to
light that donatelle has been away
for so long i think that's gone on a lot
mike i do think there's been a lot
of a lot more people within the league
who have come down with the virus
and hey just we'll see you next week
we'll see you in two weeks whatever
and nobody in the public finds out i
think it's been a more common story than
we would realize
so one of the problems of the media not
being in the locker room yep
and it's one of the problems of this
shroud of secrecy that the teams in the
league
are putting up uh for pr purposes
frankly they don't want
they don't want us talking about
all these people who are having more
than
mild symptoms or no symptoms at all they
don't want it because
uh you know it's just the bad look that
they're pushing forward
and putting people's health and lives in
danger although
the irony here and i think i'm using it
correctly i never know
the irony is that's the kind of thing
that if they properly
paid attention to it and shined a light
on it
it could get the players to take it all
more seriously but maybe they realize
the players aren't going to take it
seriously until it actually touches them
in some way and it's not going to touch
them until it takes away
their paychecks hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports